let's get reaction now from the chairman
of two major House committees looking
into all this trey Gowdy is chairman of
the House Oversight and Government
Reform Committee and Bob Goodlatte
chairs the House Judiciary Committee
gentlemen thanks for being here
chairman Gowdy first to you just a broad
overview what strikes you about this
report
what's hitch hits you when you look at
the 568 pages just what a dark day it is
for the FBI and the DOJ two institutions
our country desperately needs we
desperately have to be able to have
confidence in them and this level of
bias and animus not only didn't want to
stop the Trump campaign he wanted to
stop the Trump presidency this is an
epic truck Peter struck the the FBI
agent who is on Hillary Clinton's
investigation and arguably the lead
Russia investigator not only wanted to
stop his campaign but once he won got on
the motor probe because he wanted to
impeach him that is a level of animus
and bias that everyone should reject and
Chris Rae I'm sorry you're wrong
Chris there are consequences the
consequences are that your fellow
citizens questioned whether or not they
can have confidence in the world's
premier law enforcement agency and
that's coming from someone who's
defended him a lot throughout his career
this was a bitterly disappointing report
general good luck well first of all this
report shows that there was special
treatment given to Hillary Clinton in
the investigation of her case there are
there is not standard procedures
followed in investigating her and there
was special treatment given there's no
doubt that this was not proper process
and the report shows time and time again
how director Comey and others made
mistakes errors in judgment or
deliberate people can draw their own
conclusions but it was improperly
handled and as Trey said you then put
that up against how the investigation
has been handled into the so-called
Trump Russia collusion and you have a
contrast that is shocking in terms of
how they handle the one presidential
campaign compared to another it's got to
be investigated further changes got to
be made I will compliment director ray
on some of the personnel changes that
have been made I
compliment him on saying that they're
sobering lessons learned from this we
need to see changes made so in 2020 we
don't see another presidential campaign
handled like this so when you hear
Republicans and people who've been
looking into this and say this 568 pages
is there's just not a lot there or that
Horowitz kind of left something on the
table how do you respond this is a very
thorough investigation he takes minutiae
and examines each piece carefully draws
his conclusions and I commend him I
think it's a a well done report and I
never expected he would would find every
single thing as some critics have said
but he did find all kinds of
irregularities here when you couple that
with the the struck page text including
this new one that has come out recently
where part of it was redacted by the way
we only recently learned the whole
sentence about second part we're going
to stop yeah Donald Trump from being
president on States that is improper for
the FBI and quite frankly this is the
world's premier law enforcement
organization and it's besmirching the
reputation of tens of thousands of brave
men and women who keep us safe prevent
terrorist attacks fight crime every
single day and a handful of people in
the hierarchy of the organization have
caused serious damage all right let's
put up the August 8 2 2016 that is the
one where a page says Trump's never
going to be president right right and
struck Texas text back that part was
redacted in the document she received no
no he's not we'll stop it here's another
part that we believe in November 22nd
2016 FBI attorney one is it making you
rethink your commitment to the Trump
administration I think that's Lisa page
attorney - hell no viva la resistance
and we believe that's Peter struck let
me play this soundbite congressman Gowdy
from Jim Comey in his interview here in
special report I asked about these
struct page texts and if he knew now
what he knew then what he would do I'd
have removed both of them from any
contact with
investigations so shouldn't they're
working including those involving
anybody connected to president Trump but
beyond that because judge product then
be questioned sure it's a reasonable
question asking everybody including
print the candidate Trump Peter struck
interviews Hillary Clinton deals with
the the bleached bits and the server and
Cheryl Mills all of that interviews
Michael Flynn and is integral in this
whole case but he's one of many other
people involved in all the things you
just ticked off when I saw that the text
I was deeply disappointed in them but I
never saw any bias any bias
well he's not reading the same text I'm
reading on the Peter struck said that
the vote should be one hundred million
to zero he can't think of a single
solitary American that should vote for
Donald Trump to be President he said
he'll stop it as a candidate he talked
about impeachment once he won actually
director Comey unwittingly just proved
the point of the question you asked him
on follow-up would you have kept him on
the investigation had you known what you
know now and he said no okay why not
because bias is that insidious that is
that pervasive it colors your ability to
do what we need the FBI to do which is
to be fair in fact century so of course
you're gonna fire him the day you learn
in my head I go back when did you start
working on the case that's when you
should have been fired so whatever he
did on either these investigations Brett
it is it has to be viewed through the
prism that he can't think of a single
solitary person that should vote for
this man to be President so Struck's
attorney says this is taken out of
context it didn't affect his decisions
some people say what happens in the
context of those texts did they know
something about the Russia information
and that's what they're referring to do
you think that this changes at all in
context or any vacuum it's it's just
damning it changes a lot going forward
because I don't know how my fellow
citizens are going to be able to have
confidence I mean Russia did something
to our country in 2016 it was serious it
deserved to be investigated it deserved
to be investigated by a fair FBI agent
who was not talking about impeach
the person that he was investigating his
lawyers just wrong that bias did impact
something he was so hyper-focused on
trunk that he ignored the Weiner Abidine
emails and it called Jim Comey to have
to send a letter a month later than he
should have said it
the other point Brett is this why is it
our job to prove this trucks bias
impacted his decision-making I got a
better idea struck you come before
Congress you come before the American
public and prove to us that your
manifest animus towards Donald Trump did
not affect your decisions let me ask one
more question on this because trey is
exactly right we have been requesting
that he be produced as witness for quite
some time now and that that agreement is
not reached we are very shortly going to
issue a subpoena for him to appear
speaking of that there's also documents
that you want that you still haven't
received in this process is yeah we have
set up a better process we're making
progress we actually have a room down at
the Department of Justice where they are
producing tens of thousands of documents
and our investigators are going through
those identifying the ones that we want
produced they are producing them so
we're making progress in that regard but
we also have other documents they have
not produced and that we are making
progress on that we have meetings coming
up shortly on how to get those
additional documents requested produced
it's the American people right to know
the Congress is their representatives
these documents have got to be produced
there is no reason not to producing
chairman Gowdy the last time you you
talked about the FBI inner workings it
was about this allegation of Spygate and
and all of that you said at the time
that you thought that the president and
others would think that the FBI was
doing what they were supposed to be
doing in context of this and and you're
animated about what you're learning out
of this IG report does it change your
perspective of how this is all
progressed even when it comes to the
Russia investigation Brett I'm animated
because Russia tried to undermine the
fundamentals of our democracy in 2016
and I think anyone who heard what any
law enforcement agency heard in the
summer of 2016
every one of my fellow citizens would
say you go find out whether that's
true or not you go find out whether or
not a foreign hostile country is going
to mess with our election what my fellow
citizens also expect is for the agent
that does the follow-up to be free of
taint and bias like 99% of the FBI
agents are it just so happened the one
pick to follow up and leave the Russia
investigation has manifest animus and
can't think of a single person to vote
for Donald Trump so those two are
inextricably intertwined most of my
fellow citizens would say yeah I want to
know what Russia was doing to us in 2016
but also won't the person that's finding
out that's investigating it to be free
of bias and free of taint and they would
say Muller fired that guy he did fire
him and and god only knows what damage
he was done before mother-father this is
what's so pervasive about bias Brett it
doesn't matter what Muller comes up with
some people are going to believe because
strokes level of animus was so high that
you can't remove the tape that's wide
bias is so destructive in a justice
system chairman Goodlatte this is what I
hear on email on Twitter on Facebook
they hear us reporting on these 560
eight pages they've been waiting for
months and months and months and they
hear what is coming out of it who is
going to pay for something that was done
wrong in their mind and investigation
after investigation it seems like it
comes to a head and then nothing happens
absolutely hundreds of classified emails
or handled improperly in violation of
the law and no one has been held
accountable in that regard now we now we
see that if that whole process of that
investigation was handled with extreme
bias and a whole host of questionable
actions and people need to be held
accountable some of those people are no
longer employed at the Federal Bureau of
Investigation and the Department of
Justice that's a good thing but we're
going to continue to follow through
until we're sure that changes have been
made so that these things can't occur in
the future and we don't have a 20/20
that looks anything at all like 2016 in
terms of
this kind of mishandling of
investigations of the highest level of
importance when you're talking about the
two candidates for president eights so
Trey and I are going to have a joint
hearing next Tuesday where we'll have
the inspector general will be able to go
into this 560 page report and ask
manifold questions and then the
following week we have already requested
the Deputy Attorney General United
States mr. Rosen Stein and the FBI
director Christopher ready to come
forward and talk to us and answer our
questions based upon that report all
right other quick Nuggets here in this
IG report it says definitively that
Hillary Clinton's emails were hacked by
foreign actors of some kind me tell you
why that's so important because when
they're religious right all the denials
I mean we went through all of these
stages that it wasn't happening well but
but we got a little window into that
when Jim Comey one of Jim Comey's
original memo drafts had that language
in there and it was edited out let me
get why it's important there are two
reasons they cite for not prosecuting
Hillary Clinton number one that she
didn't have specific general intent and
number two she didn't expose it to
foreign actors we now know one of those
reasons is bogus and had they done a
good job of interviewing her had they
not made up their mind six weeks before
they went to interview her perhaps they
could have found evidence of an intent
to commit a crime but they didn't look
for they made up their mind before they
ever interviewed her but but that is
really important that Horowitz and
others some of our colleagues that
unlock the fact that those emails were
exposed to foreign actors most of the
rank and file if the I agents thought if
I did this I'd be prosecuted that's in
the IG report absolutely and we found
other precedents where people were
prosecuted for similar actions contrary
to what the FBI director concluded the
Weiner investigation case was slow
walked no question because Peters truck
was so obsessed with with with Donald
Trump in the fall of 2016 that he sat on
emails about the Tom Comey got to him
and sent the letter we world the eve of
an election but in September when they
learned about this he did nothing
because he was hyper focused on Trump
and if I were a Democrat or an
independent or any American I'd be
concerned about how director Comey
handled that aspect of which is also
criticized by the the inspector general
why would you like out of the way you
release that information play for let me
play that this is the election stop one
from Jim Comey weeks went by without any
action I do know that New York and FBI
headquarters became aware that there may
be some connection between weiners
laptop and the Clinton investigation
weeks before it was brought to me for
decision I don't know whether they could
have moved faster and why the delay so
was it the threat that the New York
agents were gonna leak that it existed
really what drove you to the not
concealed part I don't know why there
was if there was slow activity why it
was slow for those first couple weeks
there's at least one agent who says that
he knows that they wouldn't be
prosecuted anyway
well I a couple of points so what
director Comey said he he used the word
index he didn't properly index the fact
that OMA Abidine was married Anthony
Weiner he may be the only person in the
Western Hemisphere that did not know
they were married that's one of his
excuses it took a prosecutor or an agent
from the Southern District of New York
calling to Washington specifically
saying what in the hell are you doing
and what is taking so long that's what
finally got him to move mckay wasn't
moving and struck wasn't moving someone
struck and pages text messages may still
be missing how g says that we we keep
looking for them he's actually done a
good job he's the one who found the
first big batch of missing text messages
and made those available back to the
department which then made them
available to us but yes I think we've
actually benefited in a multitude of
ways from this investigation it's filled
in pieces of the puzzle but it's also
resulted in more information coming to
us just in the last few days and weeks
around it that winner and loser in this
IG report in your mind well
unfortunately I think that trey is right
that the Federal Bureau of Investigation
as a whole is a
and I hope that Christopher Rea is
taking his sobering lesson to heart that
he can do great things to restore the
public's trust in this very important
organization which we all should trust
and I think 99% of the time we should
absolutely the winner is Michael
Horowitz because he proves that you can
be Fairfax century can conduct a series
investigation the loser is every one of
my fellow citizens who wants an FBI and
the Department of Justice that they can
believe in all of us have lost when we
have a department and a bureau that we
cannot have confidence at chairman Gowdy
chairman Goodlatte we appreciate your
time and we'll continue to follow up
thanks Brett